according to a survey released this week
by Consumer Reports
the word natural on food products
actually means nothing literally nothing
that's right so we've got some findings
from the study so two thirds of
Americans think that the word natural on
the label of a packaged or processed
food means that it contains no
artificial ingredients pesticides or
genetically engineered organisms that is
simply not true when consumers see the
word on meat or poultry seventy percent
think it means no growth hormones were
used to get the animal in the animals
feed and sixty percent think the animals
got no antibiotics or other drugs in
their feed that is also not true
both the FDA and the US Department of
Agriculture allow food producers to use
the word natural on labels as long as
nothing artificial or synthetic has been
added that would not normally be
expected in the food under an informal
policy the FDA put into place back in
1993 and the arguments been made that
the prohibition of the word natural
would restrict free speech so we we do a
lot of stuff on this show about natural
foods and GMOs and all the crazy
additives and the sugars and knife
dough's corn syrup and all that
Jacqueline I'm gonna let you start here
as someone with a little science behind
it
we love words right we just love words
you throw natural on it people think
nature I mean it says right there that
it's just what you wouldn't already
expect to be in the food so if something
unnatural is being added to your food
but it's something that they normally
add they're allowed to use the word
natural and put that label on the food
and people I'm sorry but like I do
honestly think that they have the right
to do that
people being gullible is not their fault
I mean people exploit that type of thing
all the time politicians do it and
marketers do it so it's kind of up to
the consumer to do a little bit of work
and a little bit of research to figure
out what is in their food and what is
healthy and what's not and the whole
anti GMO think to people get excited
they see non-gmo on a food and they'll
buy it I've seen non-gmo on salt I mean
that's an inorganic there's no g2m
I don't understand like people just they
see words that are pretty and they think
that they're doing something good by
going after that food so you're kind of
giving the FDA a little a little leash
here to fiddle around because you want
it to ultimately come back to the people
you have to be manipulative and I wish
that it wouldn't happen but I mean
that's all for the world that we live in
and as far as like the money is
concerned you have to follow the money
if this is gonna make corporations more
money no one's going to stop them yeah
so I'm sort of with you because I
believe in the personal responsibility
thing but if this many people are
getting duped perhaps the FDA needs to
do something more more transparent to
raise the standards I I hurt you you
tell me if this is correct or not
I heard that apparently there's a
certain like percentage of insects that
are allowed in peanut butter it's like a
point five situation just simply because
of the quantity of mass production that
you have to allow that just margin of
toxicity even your there's a certain
amount of bone that's allowed to be in
the McDonald's weenie and stuff because
because of just the volume and so they
have to permit that but what I am
shocked by is just how low the bar has
been set whereas like all natural is not
they're like oh this doesn't have
formaldehyde and you know rat poison so
yes it's all natural
it's about instead of all natural being
about what it is it's now about what
it's not they're like oh well it well
doesn't have tar and it is all natural
right do you think so if they changed it
to be a little more honest wouldn't the
company's the food companies just figure
out other ways of manipulating people
yeah and they do I mean that's not the
only thing I've seen you know as far as
manipulation goes I mean I've seen
people you know who are concerned with
animal right give no mind to factory
farming because instead of factory
farming they say farm fresh and
technically it's a farm it's so they can
say farm fresh and no one bats an eye at
that I mean it's no secret that 50% of
the antibiotics and you know that are
being used go into the food that you're
consuming and instead of instead of you
know marketing like that they'll say you
know due to advanced farming techniques
we've taken advanced veterinary measures
you know and people see that and they're
like oh that sounds great but they have
no idea that it's saying we're pumping
your food full of antibiotics right so
is that part of it that especially
in America cuz a lot of the stuff that
we allow in our food in America is not
allowed in Europe is it part of it that
we just love stamps on things we love
like a logo that says something you know
just some catch phrase or authorized by
or certified by and we don't do any of
the work when you when you go shopping
do you look for those things even if
you're not even sure what they mean you
know just a stamp on the thing that says
it depends on what it is I think I feel
like I was raised to be pretty healthy
and so I look you know I look for brown
eggs I look for you know like there's
certain things that I do look at but I
feel like 90% of the grocery store
contains all these chemicals that the
Smarty is quoting I don't remember but
but how can you avoid it I try to shop
around the outside perimeter get the
fresh veggies veggies and lettuce and
what-have-you
there's G but I did to answer your
question though I do believe that
America is addicted to brands and labels
for sure we're all you know it's all
about status it's all about you know I
honestly I think the hope you can
gluten-free movement really push push
that kind of obsession when it comes to
one's own diet you know shopping the
restaurant I am gluten free and just
declare that to the restaurants so that
everyone knows yeah which actually I
know there's been studies saying that
most people unless you have celiac
disease and there's basically no such
thing as being good gluten intolerant
when I'm sure there'll be another study
that'll reverse that next week anyway so
just be kind of a little more aware of
what you're putting in your body because
this packaging clearly isn't telling you
the truth